all right guys
bang bang i've got a very special treat
for you today i've got everett here with
me thank you so much for doing this sir
so let's jump into this and uh tell us
kind of your background how did you get
into
the finance world and then we'll get
into building grow
yeah totally uh so i i started out when
i was in college i was really interested
in markets i
started a couple companies when i was
younger and then started trading stocks
and
i loved like that world i
left college went into investment
banking i didn't really know what
you know difference investment banking
or trading or uh
you know anything was but this it was on
wall street literally as i went to
deutsche bank
uh and spent about two years there doing
uh doing investment banking
uh during that period i started in 2007
i left in 2000 in 2009
uh during that period like the great you
know the great financial crisis happened
um and what was like really interesting
to me or what was like really
sort of a surprising to me was how few
people you know understood what was
happening even while it was happening
um even inside you know one of the
largest investment banks uh in the world
and uh at that point i was i i got
really interested in global macro
uh i started reading what you know what
peter thiel was writing and
uh you know and some of the other like
luminaries in the space like san diego
miller and
and other people and uh and felt like
these were the people that really only
got
the only people that really got it that
understood what was actually happening
at the time not even like in the future
uh and that's what i wanted to do i
realized that and so i went to
i left oyster i went to sac capital um
worked for actually for dan tapiero
who's on the show recently
um uh and then spent a couple other
years
at other hedge funds leading and growing
research uh and investing for
for for kind of managers in that space
got it
dan is uh fantastic he came on and gave
me the uh the hard pitch on the golden
bitcoin both
so yeah it definitely is great so
as after you did that um you eventually
end up teaming up
with uh partner and you start row tell
us a little bit about just what the
impetus for the idea was
yeah i mean it was it was pretty simple
at the time um
it got more complex but it was really
that uh
you know that fintech had been going
after the very bottom of the market for
a very long time uh not
basically since fintech had started if
you think about fintech kind of starting
in 2010
you know primarily on the consumer side
it was like companies like chime
that went after you know the lowest end
of consumers and on the business side
too it was companies like
uh you know all like the lending the
lending networks that start businesses
we're generally going after like very
small kind of mom-and-pop type
businesses
um and i think there's just this
assumption in the market
that if a company is big whether they've
raised venture capital or they have a
lot of people
um they have some sort of operational
complexity that
because they're a good client of the
bank uh they're generally happy the bank
is
you know is taking care of them and that
was something that we thought was just
fundamentally wrong we thought that
actually like
the companies the bigger they were
actually like the more problems they had
the more complexity they had
the harder it was to be like really good
at servicing them and the more
technology that they needed
to do better um that was sort of my top
down
you know 30 000 foot view i came in from
as a like investor
type and my partner alex uh who i teamed
up with
was an operator he was chief product
officer of a company called list
which has you know a couple hundred
people between new york and london uh
and it's scaled a couple other companies
in the past uh and he would hit these
growing pains every time he came into a
company and you know took it from 30 to
you know 100 200 people
um so our perspective was that we can
fix that and that this is like actually
the best way to
you know go into this market that's 120
billion market that is
pretty commoditized um and uh
but has like a lot of room for growth if
you can like move past the basic
product um got it and so talk a little
bit about as you guys have
started building the business it seems
like you've got a ton of different kind
of product lines and it really built out
a pretty compelling
uh you know solution for these types of
high growth businesses what does that
look like in practice in terms of the
the various touch points you have with
the customer yeah
i mean so we started out just building
the basic like banking sort of core
infrastructure right
checking account we have a treasury
management product um
and a card product uh this is kind of
like the the building blocks for
for everything else that came after that
um and then we started going past so
like building
uh building a comprehensive like
budgeting platform that allows companies
to set you know quarterly annual budgets
for
different lines and attribute all their
expenses to those
um you know deeper syncing with
accounting that way everything kind of
is live
real time uh user management accounts
payable like there's a there's a lot
in the product um you know not every
company uses everything that's kind of
the point it's meant to be kind of
continue to grow with you
but um you know the our perspective is
always like that that the financial
services are
they need to be best in class they need
to be priced competitively um
but fundamentally like what what matters
is like the stuff that actually helps
people get their job done every single
day
um and so that's where we invest all our
time and as we grow like you know we
think about
what do we add that's adjacent to our
product that you know cfos
and finance teams are using every single
day that's interfacing with banking
um and that's where we'll continue to
grow i mean we just launched
accounts payable um which again it
always blew my mind that that was like a
separate product to begin with that a
company like
likebill.com for example can be so big
uh performing such a
you know uh discrete function um
so that's that's kind of where we're
headed got it and
why the focus on those high growth
businesses like like there's tons of
checking products there's tons of
treasury management products
but like you're not only differentiating
in some of the features um and kind of
the efficacy of the product
but you're also specifically focusing on
a certain part of the market so
like how do you think about that market
i mean what we thought we thought very
early on was like the market does not
need another checking account right the
market does not need another bank
account
yeah you can do low fees and all that
stuff that's been done 100 times
uh not to say that someone won't make
money doing that but
that wasn't the game we wanted to play
um you know what the market
did need was like companies need help as
they grow
uh and they need help from a personal
level and they need help from a
technology level
and banks weren't automatically
overnight gonna become great at building
technology and software like they're not
right like most of the software that you
buy from a bank or the software that you
rent from a bank i guess
is like fis or fiserv right it's built
by like one of the core companies not
even built by the bank
um so we're not really competing with
them and on that level at all
we don't feel like we really compete
with anybody on the software level
um we compete with banks on the on the
product level but we're you know
generally better priced than them to
begin with um
the uh so i mean that's that's sort of
how we
you know what we try to build in terms
of like thinking about high growth
customers
and uh and why we go towards them it's
actually more that they come towards us
uh you know we're open to anybody um
but like i would say like we're not the
best option if you're a company that's
just getting started and you need a
basic checking account
tons of people that can do that for you
as you start to get bigger and bigger
and have more people and more complexity
and need an all-in-one solution like
that's where we're the best and and
that's where we will stand against
anybody in the market
uh and and when and so um that's sort of
how we
how we got there it's not we don't have
an industry specific vertical we're not
like
banking for startups or banking for econ
or banking for
you know like marketing or banking for
plumbers like whatever you know there's
this big thesis out there that like
there's gonna be all these banking for
companies uh like
i i like i strongly reject that i think
it's way too hard to build i think it's
really hard to be really excellent at
this
and i don't think they're gonna be a
thousand companies that are excellent at
it
yeah and help me understand like if i'm
a startup founder
you know i start out there's two or
three folks on my team uh we start
building
uh we hit this kind of inflection point
we start to scale is it
difficult to get folks to kind of
transition from whatever their original
banking service was
to you and kind of how do you think
about um you know
is a somebody who doesn't appear to be a
competitor because they're just so
far uh you know in a different part of
the market
can they basically entrench themselves
and make your job harder or how do you
kind of
convince people to basically um you know
abandon the solution they started with
and really move to you guys
uh it's like it's one of those things
that it's it's actually not as hard as
it
sounds people like people do build it up
they're like uh like switching banks
it's such a pain like and it's
you know it's like if you're big it's
like an hour of work and if you're small
it's like
20 minutes uh like it's it's really not
that bad
uh we have a team that is here to
actually help them transition so
uh you know companies come to us and
they want help moving all their stuff
we'll do it for them
uh but um but from uh
no i mean it's it's a pretty open
ecosystem um
you know banking is like is is very uh
is in a lot of ways very low tech um and
so from
uh uh it
it's not that bad but it is like
something that people overstate
all the time got it how did covet 19 in
the pandemic
uh the macro environment like all the
kind of craziness and uncertainty and
chaos that happened in 2020
how did that affect your business did it
accelerate was there some obstacles
it definitely accelerated i mean i think
in two ways both in terms of you know
new customer growth
and existing customer growth um like we
saw the companies on our platform some
of which you know grew 200 300
uh during the crisis because they were
high growth companies to begin with
companies that understood
technology again whatever vertical
you're in uh
you know did pretty well through the
crisis and it was generally companies
that were slower
attached more to the physical world
bricks and mortar stuff like that that
you know unfortunately like had a really
tough time so
um yeah you know it definitely like
helped uh our companies and our
companies have i think
emerged stronger in the past year than
where they were before
got it and then in terms of um
where you guys go from here right what
is kind of the
product roadmap look like um and how do
you kind of see the business evolving
i mean i don't want to give too much to
the way in terms of product roadmap
because i know our competitors watch
everything we do these days come on
but you know uh look i mean we're trying
to just continue to make like the cfo's
life simpler the company's life the
employees live simpler and work better
together with money that's our mission
statement that's our ethos
is helping people work better together
with money and uh
and so we will continue to build product
you know where there's this fragmented
verticalized ecosystem
where cfos generally have to juggle
between seven and ten products like we
want to make that ultimately one or two
um and so we will just continue to move
down that line
uh at a measure base uh and try to again
just add value to our customers and
bring the ecosystem together you know
there's a the ben horowitz or uh
i'm rick andreas and i forget which one
of them uh quote right but that
everything is either bundling or
rebundling
unbundling or rebundling uh you're very
much in the rebundling
uh business and uh and believe that the
time is now
for that um you know i think it's all
everything about startups and about
especially about that is about timing um
and
uh and so yeah so we'll keep we'll keep
rebundling
got it uh you mentioned cfos and it's
interesting that you specifically target
one person
in the executive team of these companies
and you kind of know hey look that's the
person that we're trying to make their
life easier
to talk a little bit about them as
customers like what are some of the
things that maybe you guys understand
that would be surprising to people who
don't spend all day thinking about
you know making a cfo's life easier are
there certain complexities or obstacles
that they deal with that were surprising
or
uh maybe some you know anecdotes in
terms of things that cfos have said to
you in the past that
you know really kind of seared in your
brain and you guys remember
yeah i mean i think you know for us like
our customers the whole company
like it is you know from the employee
the employees
all the way up to the ceo but the cfo is
really the decision maker and the buyer
for us
uh and he's the one that's you know
that's evaluating all the service
providers and choosing row versus others
um i think it's i think there's two
things that really like
that motivate you know that person uh
when it comes to this particular space
um one is like they understand that like
no product is perfect
and that like and that having like a
level of support uh
and a person behind that is incredibly
valuable uh
there was a a a really dumb banker
saying
uh that like when i'm one met with this
like you know like
50 billion dollar bank in the midwest uh
we were like looking for our partner
bank
they were like yeah cfos just want one
neck to one neck to strangle
just like a really off-color odd uh i
guess
you know old-school banking thing i
haven't been in the banking world for
very long
but uh but it's kind of true uh you know
they they want that person uh because
it's never gonna be perfect
uh or they're always gonna have
questions or there's always edge cases
banking is always
a given vegas that's one two is like uh
you know every company is a little bit
different and being able to allow them
to
set up their integrations the way they
run their accounting you know the way
that they do budgeting
like all that stuff there's no we start
you know we kind of started out with a
this is the way it should be and that's
kind of like a great ethos from a
product manager perspective right like
don't try to give the customer too many
choices uh that's not true in this world
you want
as much flexibility as possible um
because every one of these customers
looks a little bit different and we're
not going to ask them to change the way
they operate got it and are you able to
do anything in terms of once you have a
business on as a customer you pretty
much have access to
you know incredible data you understand
who's growing who's not growing
but really what you have is you've got
an ecosystem of customers and do you
guys do anything
with um you know kind of putting
customers together
or leveraging um the growing customer
base you have like how do you think
about
uh the customers in a kind of totality
um of the actual customer base is there
anything there that you guys have done
yeah i mean we try to so we'll continue
to like productize that more but we try
to put our
customers um in specific verticals
together with
you know the same account
representatives um
and he's able to connect them all the
time and connect them you know if he's
covering
uh e-commerce or another one's covering
uh specific
areas in venture uh being able to
connect them with each other connect
with investors like
that are you know also on our platform
so there's a you know similar to like i
guess what
uh some of the more established banks
will do you know for for some of their
clients
uh we we embrace that as well um and so
that is you know that is where we are
today i think as we grow
yeah like we'll look to add more
technology around that uh
and ultimately like formalize that but
but today it is uh
you know it is an incredible collective
of like super high growth super
interesting companies that are doing
they're doing cool stuff um and they
generally want to know each other so
we're happy to facilitate that
got it makes sense what's been the most
surprising thing um you know since you
started the business
um i think the most surprising thing has
been like
uh i don't know i guess
i mean i guess look i guess the most
surprising thing or for me um
coming from like a non-tech background
um has been just like the
the product development cycle um and the
fact that like you you know there's
truly like no
shortcut like it is time times people uh
add more people you can do it faster
take the same amount of people do it
slower
uh but that is it and so you need to
make be like really disciplined and
parsimonious in terms of your choices
uh about what you're going to build um
thankfully i have like an amazing
product manager as a partner who you
know
has taught me that lesson over and over
again otherwise i would have
it would have been harder but uh but
yeah that's been like kind of the most
most interesting thing i think for me
coming from the other side of the
universe
got it and then what's been the one
thing that maybe you've
really said hey you know we want to
accomplish x but you guys haven't been
able to do it yet whether it's just uh
we're not there yet in terms of building
the product uh there's some other
limitation maybe even regulation or
whatever it is is there something that
sticks out in terms of you you guys are
almost chasing it but haven't yet done
it
i mean there has honestly there hasn't
been much like we you know we've always
like
said i guess what this is the other
thing that's been surprising is like
that there's kind of nothing that you
can't do like we would always start with
something like that and then work
backwards
and find a way to do it whether it's
through a partnership or on our own
um you know it's just more that you
can't do everything all at once uh
but we haven't found anything that it's
like man i wish we could
do this thing that jp morgan can do um
you know it really is just a function of
time um
i think for us it's like you know we
want to be uh
you know we want to be a multi-billion
dollar institution we think
we'll be there by the end of this year
um and that is like what we're chasing
uh today got it it makes a ton of sense
uh bitcoin crypto blockchain kind of
this whole decentralized digital world
uh is now getting tons and tons of
attention um you
guys being in financial services is you
know somewhat tangentially related
how do you think about that space and
are you guys doing anything there
or yeah you know will you do with
something in the future
yeah i mean we started out building uh
building a lot of like a lot of
decentralized tech
uh on our ledger we ended up like using
parts of it but not not all of it
um and went more a more traditional
approach at the beginning but it's
definitely something
with myself my co-founder reciproy
meshton uh
at the start in terms of um
you know in terms of like the space yeah
like we're always looking at d5
um and is there an opportunity to be
able to you know
bring our customers into that i would
say like there's still like fundamental
challenges that that make that like
tough at the moment um but we expect
that that will change as like you know
as you have more of an ecosystem and you
can basically borrow
far from those markets in a usd like you
can't kind of
you know you have an asset liability
mismatch if you're borrowing crypto and
and your liabilities are in dollars uh
in terms of uh in terms of other stuff
you know in terms of bitcoin like
yeah i mean i was you know i was a macro
uh analyst in pm for
for a long time and i was always the
smarter guys that i worked for would
always tell me to like focus on
focus on the supply side uh of any of
any market
because it's the most predictable um
whether you're looking at oil whether
you're looking at
like stocks whether you're looking like
you can actually like solve backwards
from like supply
and that will generally give you like a
a pretty good indication of like where
mark is going to go
so like in a lot of ways like i mean
crypto and like bitcoin is like kind of
like the perfect market
it's a perfect like um because like you
do have like a fundamentally locked
blocked uh
supply that's gonna decline um you know
i
remember looking at it and i'm i feel
dumb for not buying
more of it uh you know in 20 like 11 or
2013
and i was like uh i was like this is
like the perfect
bubble in a lot of ways because it is
like literally i couldn't
you couldn't construct something that
that would uh that would
you know that would like this is exactly
what we'd look for
basically this is exactly what i would
look for as an analyst in a market
like where's the market where supply is
going down and where there's like
you know uh there's inherent demand
that's that's growing and it's like
really that simple so i think it's um
you know the market is super volatile
it'll move every day and you know it
might go up or down 30
you know but uh but like it has
you know the right characteristics
absolutely and it's pretty incredible i
think that um
it is that simple right it's just from a
market structure standpoint like the
supply goes
down down down and there's a caps
overall supply and then you get a
increasing demand and like if you took
an economics 101 course you know what
happens next right and it's all priced
up like it's not rocket science um it's
pretty simple i mean the other thing is
like markets are made at the margin
right so it doesn't take that much
buying to move it uh
like i think you know yes it's a what if
i i don't know what it is right now
truly another market cap or
whatever it is but you know how much is
actually moving every day
and settling at the end of the day not
just like trading intraday um
it's not just like any market it doesn't
take that much to move it
absolutely talk a little bit about kind
of the decentralized
uh finance movement right so you know
whether it's being built on bitcoin or
ethereum or wherever
uh just this idea of like let's build
these decentralized applications
that replace a lot of the same financial
service or banking functions
have you guys looked at that or kind of
what your thoughts there yeah
i mean we've looked at it i think you
know i think there's a really bright
future there again i think
our perspective on the space was that
the ecosystem was
like that the challenge is really
building an audience it is really
building like
uh you know a community of businesses uh
and and providing value and i think that
fundamentally as a borrower
uh which most of our businesses would be
in this instance um
you know they shouldn't really care uh
is it
you know like they just they need to be
able to grow their business that's what
they care about they're not they're not
there to make you know bets on crypto
they're not there to like
um to to do sort of stuff and defy
they just want a better product um and
so our perspective has always been like
if it gives our customer a lower cost of
interest if it gives our customer a
better borrowing experience
uh you know we will embrace it i would
say today like it's still
far off but it's not but it's moving
very fast uh to the point where i think
that there's
there's a real opportunity there and
like so much of
uh of credit of of you know
finances uh is is so manual
um and it's so old school that you know
i'm really excited about a lot of the
the developments in that space
um because i think that they will
accelerate um you know the adoption
credit and
for a lot of these customers absolutely
that makes uh makes a ton of sense
what's the one big thing that you guys
are looking forward to in 2021 you
mentioned kind of trying to accomplish a
multi-billion dollar you know kind of
institutional
um evaluation or milestone but what's
the big thing that gets you guys there
yeah i mean like multi-billion in terms
of like like the asks of our clients on
our platform and i think
we'll be there pretty fast um like what
gets us there is like just continuing to
put our heads down and execute honestly
i mean we spent two years
uh you know with like really no product
uh sorry with no market uh focusing on
product uh before we launched
um you know we think very firmly the
best product in the market wins uh we've
done like basically no marketing
like we really are you know focused on
learning from our customers growing
around them
uh and building out that way so um
you know there's a lot of other people
that are you know doing a lot of hand
waving and putting billboards everywhere
whatever we're not about that like we're
really just trying to focus and win
got it uh we didn't talk about the name
uh where did we
come from uh so row is like the
dvo one of an option right it's like if
interest rates go up by x percent
what is my option worth and it was kind
of a metaphor for like what we
how we try to help our customers right
uh it's like we're gonna improve your
trajectory a little bit
not a ton like that's up to you but you
know
enough uh and and so that's sort of
where it came from
i love that
um in terms of uh the fintech space in
general
it seems like everyone is spacking going
public
raising monster rounds like just the
interest from the public markets and
how large late stage uh growth investors
is off the charts
is that something that's uh kind of a
bubble or frothy
and like yeah there's a point in time
where this all is fun and games but like
it's getting out of hand
or do you guys feel like uh no you know
investors have it right and
uh kind of digital you know businesses
that focus on the finance industry are
really just getting started
and i'm cheating because asking somebody
who's building a company in the space is
uh
uh probably a little biased but i mean i
am uh for sure i'm a little biased
because i made that
you know this is the bet that i made
with with my career uh
i had the same conversation two years
ago uh with my with our investors
like ah this is a bubble you know so you
know valuation should be here blah blah
blah
uh and i was like no it's it's a new
asset class it's not a mobile like
venture you know at the time was 500
million 500 billion dollars versus like
pe which was like 2 billion
now it's like a billion versus 2 billion
uh but
uh i absolutely i'm sorry trillion
versus two trillion uh i
absolutely don't think it's a bubble um
i think that there's two things that are
happening one uh
interest rates are zero right real rates
are negative that means future value
equals present value for all intents and
purposes so
find something that's going to grow like
it should be worth a lot today even if
they're not making that much money today
uh if interest rates go back up which is
like a very big if
uh like that will change a bit but like
that is appropriately priced for where
we are today in the cycle and investors
should understand that
uh i think the second thing is that it
has never been possible
in history at least as far as i know to
uh to build companies from the ground up
that you know
can compete with you know 50 100 billion
dollar companies that exist in public
markets today
uh and as an investor you know would i
rather put a billion dollars into
stripe or whatever the new stripe is or
like you know
t-sis or you know one of these like like
world pay or something like that
right like i would much i can i can
guarantee you
it's gonna be more valuable in an
earlier stage company uh
that can replicate you know what is what
exists today in public markets then what
is this public markets and private
markets are only about six percent of
public markets overall
right if you think about total market
cap globally so
no i think it's a new reality and i
think that it is like uh
you know comparisons to the previous
bubble or pretty misplaced
um it's a new asset class yeah
i i tend to agree with you and i think
also the thing that people are uh
underestimating and maybe um you know
kind of just completely missing is the
global nature
of this uh and also just how much more
efficient
how much more profitable how much more
scalable uh the digital versions are
right or kind of these like
wage uh technologies and some of it's
literally like
you're a digital business and the
competitor you have as a digital
business but
you're using technologies that are far
superior and therefore more scalable
more efficient
um you know kind of more valuable to the
customer uh and in some cases
literally you're going up against a bank
that sells a tax machine right like like
it really
i'm all over the place but uh it seems
like you guys really have an advantage
from
the position you're coming from yeah i
mean i just think that there's so much
there's opportunity everywhere you know
nuts and space we're doing and consumer
and
like all over fintech um like i don't
think you know
the the top five banks uh have been the
top five banks for the past 30 years
literally
um i think the next 20 years like that
that will not be the case like it will
be someone like us someone like chime
um that will be that will be up there
yeah i love that
uh before i finish up i always ask
everyone the same three questions and
you'll get to ask me one to finish
up uh the first one is more serious
what's the most important book that
you've ever read
uh that's a good question uh i think the
most impactful
book i ever read was uh a book called
the inner game of tennis
uh i believe that so it was written in i
think like 1979 or something like that
and it was uh but it's about a
about a hundred page book it's pretty
short um
and it's really about like embracing a
performance mindset
um i it was given to me when i like
started
uh trading uh uh from another pm
and uh it was uh it's a great book
it's it's a great book for no matter
what you're doing but especially if
you're in a performance driven job
um where you really have to you know
learn how to like focus on your
uh on on your insights and
instincts uh and sort of quiet quiet
like the
uh sort of part of your mind that is
that is fighting that uh because that's
where like you know if you're playing
tennis okay like you just you just have
to go
flow and but if you're doing anything
else right if you're running a portfolio
like you have insights that other people
don't see and those are hard to kind of
get at
like your brain is constantly telling
you you know no like and you have to
unlock that a little bit or if you're
building a company the same thing
like so i thought that was a really good
one i've read it about four times i
should probably
read it again uh but uh but yeah i love
that
i've never heard of that book so i'll
definitely check it out uh next one's a
little bit more personal
uh and this is a question sponsored by
eight sleep which has got this uh kind
of cool
mattress uh mateo the ceo
got on me and said hey man you gotta
start sleeping more use this thing
uh and all of a sudden now i feel like
i'm sleeping on an ice block but
i get deeper rem sleep uh and it pretty
much changed the way that
uh i schooled during the day how do you
sleep are you a four or five hour person
are you a 10 hour person
what's kind of your sleep routine i i
have a two-year-old daughter
so my sleep routine has changed a lot in
the past couple years uh i'm uh
let's see i i'm basically my sleep
revolves around her uh basically so when
she goes to bed i try to go to bed and
then she wakes up earlier than me and
it's like hitting me on the head
you know whatever 6 a.m i i uh
uh i recently started asking this
question so i don't have a ton of data
points
but uh every single person with a kid
under the age of three years old makes
sure that that is a known part of the
the change in the sleep routine so it's
a big change
the young child is uh is now the boss it
seems like
totally absolutely uh and then uh
my final question before you get asked
me one is more fun which is
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
can i be in the middle like i wouldn't i
think there's like a decent chance
uh but i you know it's not a belief or
non-belief thing it's a probability i
think it's it's a non-zero probability
okay and uh if you're in the middle i'm
gonna assume you're similar to me of
like
yes there it's highly probable that just
given
how big the universe is uh it you know
there's some form of intelligent life
but they're not little green men that
visited earth type thing right
yeah yeah i think that's right the
universe is pretty big uh
so there's probably some something out
there most likely mathematically
but uh you know they probably haven't
been here we probably haven't been there
but i don't know there's a lot yeah you
gotta ask smarter people that that one
that's uh that's overrated
there's a guy in i think he's from
israel he was like
in charge of you know extraterrestrial
search in israel or whatever
and uh now he's come out he's older and
he's claiming that there's like a
galactic federation and uh
all the planet are all part of it i was
like
i was like you might have stared in the
telescopes for too long or something
i mean yeah i don't know i don't know
you got to get elon musk on the show and
ask
ask him that absolutely uh you could ask
me one question to finish up what do you
got for me
all right well what do you think i mean
look uh you know it's been a crazy world
for
for crypto uh like are we
you know are we over hyped at this point
is this the beginning of of
you know the next the next wave uh
uh you know where do you think how do
you think we
shape out here yeah so i think that um
i have three separate thoughts that are
all related one is
uh we are at the start of what i'll call
it the institutional bull market so kind
of last two or three bull markets have
really been retail driven
this is the first institutional bull
market so it's got room to run
from like a price standpoint how high it
goes how long it lasts you know
again people are smarter than me we'll
figure that out but just like hey the
institutions are now
here they're buying bitcoin they're
starting to look at the space like
they're taking this much more seriously
than they ever have
and i think that only gets more
pervasive and more significant over time
um two is uh everyone is probably
drastically
underestimating how important and big uh
just this general move is
so i you know i basically think of it in
two different frameworks so one is like
the digital version of all of these
businesses
is going to be way bigger than the
current iteration and if you really
think like i think a lot of people
compare digital to analog
i always talk about there's almost this
like middle step
where it was like analog that went to
really electronic like with electronic
q-sips and so
there were some you know
computer-enabled type transactions but
if you look at like the technology
you're using versus some of these legacy
banks
like you guys are really digital those
banks are more kind of electronic
and so it's better than analog but like
there was still some bureaucracy and
and some pain points and middlemen and
all that you guys are removing
so i think that like digital will be
bigger than kind of electronic or analog
the other thing is that i think that the
decentralized
protocols will be bigger than their
centralized counterports
some of that will be like protocol
versus companies some of that will just
be decentralized protocol for a
centralized product
whatever it ends up being um i think
it's a ways out like maybe
you know we're like five years away from
that really being
kind of pervasive uh and so if you
really start to look at that as like
okay i want to be
in digital finance and i eventually want
to be in
digital decentralized finance bitcoin's
probably the only thing that really kind
of hits
that spot right now it's had this
incredible fun um
but like when you look at how big is
that market like
most people are talking about like you
know this bitcoin go to 100k
i'm thinking like bitcoin's 100 trillion
dollar market cap at some point in the
future
and again i don't know if that's 50
years from now
right or 20 right but it's not tomorrow
right you know i mean like
it's pretty far away and so then you get
into this world of like well okay if
that's just like the core unit of
account
like what's all the other value that
gets created like the decentralized
infrastructure decentralized lending
like
all that's going to happen um it's just
hard to tell like who builds it
and how long it takes and then the last
thing i think
is uh it's not a straight line so you
kind of have like
yes we're an institutional bull market
two we're all underestimating how big
this is gonna be
but three is like you know put your
seatbelt on because this is gonna be
super volatile along the way
right i mean you know you kind of look
like this you guys have built there's
days where you probably feel you fork
and it's like we're gonna you know be
the next uh top five bank and then
there's days where you're like
oh my god like you know the house is on
fire right and sometimes that may happen
in the morning and afternoon in the same
day
just given like you know the challenges
of building so
i think that uh people just have to
remember like you know
there's gonna be price corrections along
the way there's gonna be protocols that
you know uh fail and kind of all of that
type of stuff and so it's
you can be bullish on a really long time
verizon but also be
you know somewhat patient in the short
to medium term and understand like
all great things just take time to build
and so i think that's
how i look at it doesn't necessarily
give us answers it's like where people
should put their money
i think it's a framework that kind of
rationally explains like
where we go uh that's awesome
that is uh thank you yeah absolutely uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about roe
yeah uh so you can come see us at row
rho
dot co um and uh and if you're a company
or
cfo or um just wanna learn more you can
book an appointment with
with one of our team members um and uh
you can find me on twitter at uh
everett cook ny uh i'm not very active
though uh we're also
row business banking ah sorry business
on twitter
we got to get you on twitter and
tweeting man i've been following you for
a while
actually i uh you know i yeah
i'm uh i'm expecting now for you to just
start with a couple of hot takes after
we do this podcast then
all right you got it
you can retweet it if i say anything for
it yeah the uh i'll retweet it be
my two-year-old keeps me awake at night
and you'll uh you'll be the most popular
guy that's right
because everyone that's right we'll
agree
awesome thank you so much for everyone i
really appreciate this and uh
i think that uh people will uh will one
uh have learned a lot but also too
i think you just sitting at a really
interesting intersection between a bunch
of different disciplines and
obviously the business you guys thought
was fantastic so highly suggest people
go check it out
road.co or go find you on twitter
awesome